you don't have to be scared everything's
gonna be amazing okay okay you've got
this yeah okay
let's do it you
grab the tissue
tissue off Kate win
Ting a young interviewer just went viral
and it's the wholesome feel-good content
we all need it was a fantastic
collaborative working environment while
promoting her latest flake Avatar the
way of water the actress chatted with a
young reporter from the German TV
Network's DDF named Martha this is your
first time yeah okay well guess what
when we do this interview yeah it's
going to be the most amazing interview
ever okay and you know why why because
we've decided that it is going to be
Martha was a little nervous because a it
was her first interview ever and B Kate
is a mega Star as scary as it was we did
have fun but Kate not only gave Martha
the most precious pep talk ever she went
full-blown hype woman so we've decided
right now me and you yeah this is going
to be really fantastic interview okay
and you can ask me anything that you
want and you don't have to be scared
everything's gonna be amazing okay okay
you've got this yeah okay let's do it
Kate even posed for this adorable selfie
with Martha and it's official if you ask
me Kate's the nicest celeb in Hollywood
it really does feel amazing ET also sat
down with Kate to talk about the film
which has officially made over one
billion dollars at the box office since
it's December 16th release
while filming her scenes for the Sci-Fi
sequel Kate held her breath for seven
minutes
shattering the record previously held by
Tom Cruise for an underwater scene in
Mission Impossible Rogue Nation where he
held his breath for six minutes it's a
lot of training it's a lot of learning
about the safety and what you have to do
to get your body to adjust and adapt to
be able to do that yes it's a physical
shift and it's something that you have
to learn how to do but at the same time
it's also a mindset in terms of
quietening your mind slowing everything
down when you are shooting in that tank
though does um number one did it take
you back to a Titanic moment literally
the only similarity between Titanic and
Avatar is that that there is some water
in it
um but no it was just totally different
you know I mean in Titanic I was never
really like I suppose I was maybe
completely submerged in water perhaps
twice I put two different scenes but
there was certainly no real need for
holding breath for any length of time
the project marks the first time Cates
worked with director James Cameron since
filming the 1997 Blockbuster type
Titanic I'll never let go
I promise
Jim is a complete genius he's an
extraordinary filmmaker and he knows
exactly what he's doing you know his
storytelling his script writing he's
extraordinary at creating not just
strong roles for women but women who are
at the center who are leaders as for
Kate one thing's for sure she's a leader
on screen and IRL
evidently amazing okay okay you've got
this yeah okay let's do it
[Music]
foreign